indeed welcome to the show peter uh
i want to know what's harder rocket
science or chess easily chess
not even a question
now why do you say that i know you just
started playing well well you started
playing again after seeing the queen's
gambit
that craze is everybody excited about
chess
why do you say chess is harder than
rocket science uh with rocket science i
have
all of my co-workers and peers able to
check my mistakes making sure i don't
make some
calculation error you know in the
mathematical sense that never happens
right
uh it happens about as much as it does
in chess which is quite frequently um
um so i i it's pretty scary considering
how many of the times we blunder
exactly it's a relief that i'm not the
only person named peter who's made a
mistake this weekend in chess so
[Laughter]
it would be an honor to have peter
svidler destroy me over the board
i would not complain
and you did play in a tournament this
weekend yes and we do have bishop g7
check landing on the board king g8 uh
will be the move played uh
you came in 27th in a group of how many
uh i think it was 89 if i remember in
your first tournament that's pretty good
uh i think so yeah um i mean
i
it was not a weekend free of errors
there are a couple of moves that i look
back deeply regretting i found the only
stalemate on the board in a completely
winning position every other move was
forced mate uh but i guess that's the
way it goes sometimes i lose my mind for
a move and just have to learn from my
mistakes you know i think we've had that
experience once it's wise guys right
absolutely uh peter i believe in making
every mistake at least twice
just to be sure it was a mistake the
first time around
to be absolutely certain of your
mistakes very important peter continue
please
now
one thing that i'm always fascinated by
are the correlations between chess and
other subjects i speak about this all
the time corporations young people
correlations between chess actually i
interviewed one neil degrasse tyson on
my twitch stream i know you know him
know of him at least what are the
correlations as he spoke to the
correlation between uh astro physics and
chess can you think of any correlations
that you find that are compelling links
between the chess process and what you
do with rocket propulsion
it's kind of interesting i never really
thought about it before but i suppose
that
you know as you go about designing any
component for any you know mechanical
system uh you need to start out by
figuring out what you need to do how you
need to do it and what the best way it
would be to do it is and i suppose it's
not unlike you know
setting up your pieces in the opening
you know you want to
get into a position where you have some
idea of what you want to do you want to
try and execute those ideas as best you
can
um
and
it's it's
you know same idea you want to do your
best you don't want to make mistakes you
want to set yourself up to make success
as easy as you can make it
strategically
when we talk rocket
rocket propulsion i got no idea
i'm a star trek fan myself but just
thinking about it in terms of uh design
uh strategic principles involved is it
pure science
or or is there room for creativity
there's certainly room for creativity
where you'll sort of go into
having
uh
you you need to choose your basic
approach you'll have certain
technologies that are common in industry
and you want to basically select from an
existing solution and then you want to
put your own spin on it such that you
know it's it's faster it's cheaper it's
more efficient uh what have you so
there's plenty of room for creativity
but you still need to have you know the
actual concrete fundamentals in place as
well
great stuff we could talk for hours is
it the show we have going on uh you did
live in st louis for some time
and left are you feeling like you wish
you had been here for all this chest
boom uh boy yeah i i took some lessons
at the chess club when i was a kid and i
am kicking myself every day for not
taking it more seriously at the time uh
i you know picking it back up i sort of
felt very natural and i wish that i had
stuck with it more seriously i feel like
i could have you know
been able to do more with my chess
career than i will now picking it up as
an adult but you know like you're in a
loser feel like rocket science
i'm sure you're going to do quite well
in what you do thank you so much for
joining us keep up the games and know
about the mistakes you got plenty more
coming trust me thank you hopefully
thank you peter thank you very much we
have our first result